these moves are going to come in handy  because one of the Backstreet Boys is  joining Dancing with the Stars Nick  Carter has reportedly been asked  multiple times to join the show and now  Us Weekly confirms he is finally going  after that coveted mirror ball trophy  and we have N Sync to thank for that big  says it was Joey Fatone who competed  twice on the show who talked him into  hitting the dance floor Nick's younger  brother Aaron also competed on the show  in season 9 placing fifth and though we  know nick has some killer dance moves he  admits he's a bit nervous saying quote I  never considered myself a great dancer  even though funny enough I've danced my  entire life I might have had a little  insecurity on that end we're predicting  he's going to do pretty well